russian invasion of ukraine
momentum is building for a war between
ukraine and russia tensions between
russia and the west are growing rapid
president biden considering deploying
thousands of troops to eastern europe
there are now a hundred thousand troops
on the eastern border of ukraine
russia is setting up field hospitals on
this border like this is what
preparation for war looks like a
legitimate war ukrainian troops are
watching and waiting saying they are
preparing for a fight the u.s has
ordered the families of embassy staff to
leave ukraine britain has sent all of
their non-essential staff home and now
the u.s is sending tons of weapons and
munitions to ukraine's army and we're
even considering deploying our own
troops to the region i mean this thing
is heating up meanwhile russia and the
west have been in geneva and brussels
trying to talk it out and sort of
getting nowhere the message is very
clear
should russia take further aggressive
actions against ukraine
the costs will be severe and the
consequences serious it's a scary grim
momentum that is unpredictable and the
chances of miscalculation and escalation
are growing i want to explain what's
going on here but i want to show you
that this isn't just typical
geopolitical behavior stuff that can
just be explained on the map instead to
understand why a hundred thousand troops
are camped out on ukraine's eastern
border ready for war
you have to understand russia and how
it's been cut down over the ages from a
slavic empire that dominated this whole
region to then the soviet union which
was defeated in the 90s and what you
really have to understand here
is how that history is transposed onto
the brain of one man this guy vladimir
putin this is a story about regional
domination and struggles between big
powers but really it's the story about
what vladimir putin really wants russian
troops moving swiftly to take control of
military bases in crimea
military hardware at the border with
ukraine
[Music]
before we go any further i want to say
thank you to today's sponsor which is
betterhelp betterhelp is a platform that
allows you to access therapy i'm a major
fan of therapy i've been doing it for
over two years now
and
it has changed my entire world i really
believe that therapy is over stigmatized
and not accessible to people and better
help is trying to change that which i
really believe in and support with
betterhelp you can quickly sign up and
you take a little quiz and it connects
you to a network of
thousands and thousands of professionals
who you can start talking with today
there are a variety of experts in
different fields of therapy within
betterhelp's network so you can find
somebody who
is right for you and for me i didn't
have any particular specific issue that
i was going to therapy for i just
started therapy and i realized that it
was just incredibly helpful to have
someone to talk to and to learn how to
express my feelings and to learn how to
talk about what was happening inside of
my brain betterhelp is not a crisis line
it's not self-help it is
licensed legitimate professional
therapist who you connect with over the
internet securely which is great because
therapy is usually really hard to figure
out where is the right therapist where
how do i get in how do i book it all of
that is usually very difficult at least
in my experience
and so better help us make it easier so
if you want to try this out you can get
10 off your first month of better health
by going to the link in my description
thank you better help for supporting my
channel for supporting this work
let's dive back in okay let's get up to
speed on what's happening here and i'm
just going to quickly give you the
highlight version of like the news
that's happening because i want to get
into the juicy part which is like why
the roots of all of this so let's go
a few months ago russia started sending
more and more troops to this border it's
this massive border between ukraine and
russia they said they were doing a
military exercise but the rest of the
world was like yeah we totally believe
you russia
this was right before this big meeting
where north american and european
countries were coming together to talk
about a lot of different things like
these countries often do in these
diplomatic summits but soon because of
russia's aggressive behavior coming in
and setting up a hundred thousand troops
on the border with ukraine
the entire summit turned into a whole
wtf russia what are you doing on the
border of ukraine meeting before the
meeting putin comes out and says
listen i have some demands for the west
and everyone's like uh okay russia what
are your demands you know we have like
coveted 19 right now and like that's
like surging so like we don't need your
like bluster about what your demands are
and putin's like no here's my list of
demands
putin's demands for the summit were this
number one that nato which is this big
military alliance between us canada and
europe
stop expanding meaning they don't let
any new members in okay
so so russia's like no more new members
to your like cool military club that i
don't like
you can't have any more members
number two
that nato withdraw all of their troops
from anywhere in eastern europe
basically putin is saying i can veto
any military cooperation or troops going
between countries that have to do with
eastern europe the place that used to be
the soviet union okay and number three
putin demands that america vow not to
protect its allies in eastern europe
with nuclear weapons l-o-l said all of
the other countries you're literally
nuts vladimir putin like these are the
most ridiculous demands ever but there
is putin with these demands these very
very aggressive demands
and he sort of is implying that if his
demands aren't met he's going to invade
ukraine i mean it doesn't work like this
this is not how international relations
work you don't just show up and say like
you can i'm not gonna allow other
countries to join your alliance because
it makes me feel uncomfortable but what
i love about this list of demands from
vladimir putin for this summit is that
it gives us a clue on what vladimir
putin really wants what he's after here
you read them closely and you can grasp
his intentions
but to grasp those intentions you have
to understand what nato is
and what russia and ukraine used to be
okay so a while back i made this video
about why russia is so damn big where i
explain how modern-day russia started
here
in kiev which is actually modern-day
ukraine in other words modern-day russia
as we know it has its original roots in
ukraine these places grew up together
and they eventually became a part of the
same mega empire called the soviet union
they were deeply intertwined not just in
their history and their culture but also
in their economy and their politics so
it's after world war ii it's like the
50s 60s 70s and nato was formed the
north atlantic treaty organization this
was a military alliance between all of
these countries that was meant to sort
of deter the soviet union from expanding
and taking over the world but as we all
know the soviet union which was russia
and all of these other countries
collapsed in 1991 and all of these
soviet republics including ukraine
became independent meaning they were not
now a part of one big block of countries
anymore but just because the borders all
split up it doesn't mean that these
cultural ties actually broke like for
example the soviet leader at the time of
the collapse of the soviet union this
guy gorbachev he was the son of a
ukrainian mother and a russian father
like he grew up with his mother singing
him ukrainian folk songs in his mind
ukraine and russia were like one thing
so there was major reluctance to accept
ukraine as a separate thing from russia
in so many ways they are one there was
another russian at the time who did not
accept this new division this young
intelligence officer vladimir putin who
was starting to rise up in the ranks of
post-soviet russia there's this amazing
quote from 2005 where putin is giving
the state of the union like address
where putin declares
the collapse of the soviet union quote
the greatest catastrophe of the 20th
century and that's for the russian
people it became a genuine tragedy tens
of millions of fellow citizens
and countrymen found themselves beyond
the fringes of russian territory do you
see how he frames this the soviet union
were all one people in his mind and
after it collapsed all of these people
who were part of the motherland were now
outside of the fringes or the boundaries
of russian territory first off fact
check
greatest catastrophe of the 20th century
like do you remember what else happened
in the 20th century vladimir
putin's worry about the collapse of this
one people starts to get way worse when
the west his enemy starts showing up to
his neighborhood to all these ex-soviet
countries that are now independent the
west starts selling their ideology of
democracy and capitalism and inviting
them to join their military alliance
called nato and guess what
these countries are totally buying it
all these ex-soviet countries are now
joining nato and some of them the eu and
putin is hating this he's like not only
did the soviet union divide and all of
these people are now outside of the
russia motherland but now they're being
persuaded by the west to join their
military alliance this is terrible news
over the years this continues to happen
while putin himself
starts to chip away
at russian institutions making them
weaker and weaker he's silencing his
rivals and he's consolidating power in
himself
[Music]
and in the past few years he's
effectively silenced anyone who can
challenge him any institution any court
or any political rival have all been
silenced
it's been decades since the soviet union
fell but as putin gains more power he
still sees the region through the lens
of the old cold war
soviet
slavic empire view he sees this region
as one big block that has been torn
apart by outside forces the greatest
catastrophe of the 20th century and the
worst situation of all of these
according to putin is ukraine which was
like the gem of the soviet union there
was tons of cultural heritage again
russia sort of started in ukraine not to
mention it was a very populous
and
industrious resource-rich place and over
the years ukraine has been drifting west
it hasn't joined nato yet but more and
more it's been electing pro-western
presidents it's been flirting with
membership in nato it's becoming less
and less attached to the russian
heritage that putin so adores
and more than half of ukrainians say
that they'd be down to join the eu 64 of
them say that it would be cool joining
nato but putin can't handle this he is
in total denial like an ex-boyfriend who
can't handle his ex-girlfriend starting
to date someone else putin can't let
ukraine go he won't let go so for the
past decade he's been trying to keep the
west out and bring ukraine back into the
motherland of russia this usually takes
the form of putin sending
secret soldiers from russia into ukraine
to help the people in ukraine who want
to like separate from ukraine and join
russia it also takes the form of oh yeah
stealing entire parts of ukraine for
russia russian troops moving swiftly to
take control of military bases in crimea
like in 2014 putin just did this to what
america is officially calling a russian
invasion of ukraine
he went down and just snatched this bit
of ukraine and folded it into russia so
you're starting to see what's going on
here putin's life's work is to salvage
what he calls the greatest catastrophe
of the 20th century the division
and the separation of the soviet
republics from russia so let's get to
present day it's 2022 putin is at it
again and honestly if you really want to
understand the mind of vladimir putin
and his whole view on this
you have to read this
on the history of unity of russians and
ukrainians by vladimir putin a blog post
that kind of sounds like a 9th grade
history essay in this essay vladimir
putin argues that russia and ukraine are
one people he calls them
essentially the same historical and
spiritual space kind of beautiful
writing honestly
anyway he argues that the division
between the two countries is due to
quote a deliberate effort by those
forces that have always sought to
undermine our unity and that the formula
they use these outside forces is a
classic one divide and rule and then he
launches into this super in-depth like
10-page argument
as to every single historical beat
of ukraine and russia's history
to make this argument that like this is
one people and the division is totally
because of outside powers i.e the west
okay but listen there's this moment at
the end of the post that actually kind
of hit me in a big way he says this just
have a look at austria and germany or
the us and canada how they live next to
each other
close in ethnic composition culture and
in fact sharing one language they remain
sovereign states with their own
interests with their own foreign policy
but this does not prevent them from the
closest integration or allied relations
they have very conditional transparent
borders and when crossing them citizens
feel
at home they create families
study work do business
incidentally so do millions of those
born in ukraine who now live in russia
we see them as our own close people
i mean
listen like i i'm not in support of what
putin is doing but like that it's like a
pretty solid like analogy if china
suddenly showed up and started like
coaxing
canada into being a part of its alliance
i would be a little bit like what's
going on here
that's what putin feels and so i kind of
get what he means there there's a deep
heritage and connection between these
people
and he's seen that falter and dissolve
and he doesn't like it he clearly
genuinely feels a brotherhood and this
deep heritage connection with the people
of
ukraine okay okay okay okay putin i get
it your essay is compelling they're at
the end you're clearly very smart and
well read but this does not justify what
you've been up to okay it doesn't
justify sending a hundred thousand
troops to the border or sending cyber
soldiers to sabotage the ukrainian
government or annexing territory fueling
a conflict that has killed tens of
thousands of people in eastern ukraine
no
okay no matter how much affection you
feel for ukrainian heritage and its
connection to russia this is not okay
again it's like the boyfriend who
genuinely loves his girlfriend they had
a great relationship but they broke up
and she's free to see whomever she wants
but putin is not ready to let go what
the hell is wrong with you i love you
jessica what the hell is wrong with you
dude don't [ __ ] touch me
i love you
[Music]
putin has constructed his own reality
here one in which ukraine is actually
being controlled by shadowy western
forces who are holding the people of
ukraine hostage and if that he invades
it'll be a swift victory because
ukrainians will accept him with open
arms the great liberator
[Applause]
like this guy's a total romantic he's a
history buff and a romantic and he has a
hill to die on here and it is liberating
the people who have been taken from the
russian motherland kind of like the
abusive boyfriend who's like she
actually really loves me but it's her
annoying friends who are planting all
these ideas in her head that's why she
broke up with me and it's like no dude
that she's she's over you what the hell
is wrong with you i love you jessica i
mean maybe this video should be called
putin
is just like your abusive exploitation
okay so where does this leave us
it's 2022
putin is showing up to these meetings in
europe to tell them where he stands he
says nato you cannot expand anymore no
new members and you need to withdraw all
your troops from eastern europe my
neighborhood he knows these demands will
never be accepted because they're
ludicrous but what he's doing is showing
a false effort to say well we tried to
negotiate with the west but they didn't
want to hence giving a little bit more
justification to a russian invasion so
will russia invade is there war coming
maybe it's impossible to know because
it's all inside of the head of this guy
but if i were to make the best argument
that war is not coming tomorrow
i would look at a few things number one
war in ukraine would be incredibly
costly for vladimir putin russia has a
far superior army to ukraine but still
ukraine has a very good army that is
supported by the west and would give
putin a pretty bad bloody nose in any
invasion controlling territory in
ukraine would be very hard ukraine is a
giant country they would fight back and
it would be very hard to actually
conquer and take over territory another
major point here is that if russia
invades ukraine
this gives nato new purpose if you
remember nato was created because of the
cold war because the soviet union was
big and nuclear-powered once the soviet
union fell
nato sort of has been looking for a new
purpose over the past couple decades if
russia invades ukraine nato suddenly has
a brand new purpose to unite and to
invest in becoming more powerful than
ever putin knows that and it would be
very bad news for him if that happened
but most importantly perhaps the easiest
clue
for me to believe that war isn't coming
tomorrow is the russian propaganda
machine is not preparing the russian
people for an invasion in 2014 when
russia was about to invade and take over
crimea this part of ukraine there was a
barrage of state propaganda that
prepared the russian people that this
was a justified attack so when it
happened it wasn't a surprise and it
felt very normal that isn't happening
right now in russia at least for now it
may start happening tomorrow but for now
i think putin is showing up to the
border flexing his muscles and showing
the west that he is earnest i'm not sure
that he's going to invade tomorrow but
he very well could i mean read the guy's
blog post and you'll realize that he is
a romantic about this he is incredibly
idealistic about the glory days of the
slavic empires and
he wants to get it back
so there is dangerous momentum towards
war and the way war works is even a
small little like fight can turn into
the other guy doing something bigger and
crazier and then the other person has to
respond with something a little bit
bigger that's called escalation and
there's not really a ceiling to how much
that momentum can spin out of control
that is why it's so scary when two
nuclear countries go to war with each
other because there's kind of no ceiling
so yeah
it's dangerous this is scary i'm not
sure what happens next here but the best
we can do is keep an eye on this at
least for now we better understand what
putin really wants out of all of this
thanks for watching
i appreciate everyone for being here i'm
excited for another year of a lot of
bigger more ambitious videos on this
channel i've been diving really deep
i've been printing a lot of things out
and reading them in hard copy which i
really like and highlighting them for
these videos which is really helpful for
me and hopefully helpful for you if you
want to support this work i have a
patreon which you can go check out
there's a link in my description and
then i also
am selling presets and luts for
video and photo it's what i use to color
this screen right now is being colored
by a lut which is a color
profile that you can put on your video
to make it look pretty this is what it
looks like without the lut hi and this
is what it looks like with the lut
it's a lot better and i have quite a few
of them that we've been working on for
probably over a year and a half with a
professional colorist it's now out and
for sale i also have them for photos as
well
thank you all for being here and
i'll see you in the next video